when I first came on to play Peter Quill
the Guardians of the Galaxy were like
you know this ragtag squad of nobody's
[Music]
I turned in my first draft of the
screenplay and I was really afraid but I
felt good about it
people didn't understand why we were
doing that space movie with a tree and a
raccoon I think the Guardians are so
imperfect their paths are not squeaky
clean this found family putting trauma
behind them to become their best selves
there's something really special about
that
[Music]
Village around the other day and was
just like they this thing is so right
like
like find us all
for each and every one of us to live
within the Marvel Universe it's been
very very special everybody always comes
to work with the same level of
excitement since day one
we are very much committed to James
Vision he's a great captain
he really believes in this story
you know we have we have so much fun
because there is so much comedy in it
and so much emotion being on set with
everyone knowing that there's a finality
to the whole experience really made me
very emotional I mean we're a family
they're all people that I want to keep
in my life to be part of something
that's just so universally beloved it's
special it's hard to even put into words
it's been it's been a blast
are you ready
[Music]
[Applause]